so you're a big supporter for free
speech yeah so the case in favor of do
you think he should be brought back
as Elon yeah because if he gets brought
back it's a higher chance that I'll be
brought back so I'm supporting that all
the way thank you Elon unban my account
um
so because you called me weak spine I'm
gonna have to message Elon okay at Omni
Destiny it was a verified Twitter
account uh Omni Destiny yeah no I'm just
kidding why'd you get banned from
Twitter Destiny I don't know I'll add
that to Elon I saw that there was a
screenshot of you uh referring to the
rape of somebody hey that was on an
older Twitter account and that was a bad
tweet you have multiple Twitter accounts
so you're trying to
um go around the bands that you keep
getting okay hold on you're slandering
me a lot right now okay let's get the
facts straight okay I don't even
remember why my first Chicago banned but
it was a wild account I tweeted some
wildly inappropriate things you regret I
don't like that word I'm gonna give the
answer to most people get but it's like
I don't regret it because I learned a
lot so I'm glad I had the bad
experiences that why don't you like the
word for good I think if we look at
where we are
how do you feel about determinism
uh I believe in hard the hardest of
determinism that's who I am okay so sure
who I am today is the culmination of
everything that's occurred in the past I
believe you speaking of Science and
truck uh I believe in you speaking about
regret is a nice way to communicate that
in this deterministic world you've
analyzed the acts of the past and you're
no longer that person yeah of course for
sure that's what that's what regret
usually means okay thanks for giving me
the human explanation okay true so in
that sense there's a lot of things I've
done that I regret oh you're what are
you you're not human you're a bot
NPC is my preferred okay all right
um I wish I would have been smart enough
at the time to not have to have had made
those mistakes okay there you go good
job um but yeah obviously really dumb
really crazy Off the Wall tweets
um but that ain't coming up man but then
I made another account
called um I can't believe I'm giving you
a history my Twitter accounts but
another account called Omni Destiny it's
an honor um and that was my I got
verified I was cool they let me have
that account because originally
abandoned I said appeal and I was like
oh let me have one more and back then
Twitter was cool and they're like okay
go for it and that account lasts for a
long time and I don't actually know 100
why that account got banned
um I believe that the tweet that showed
up in the final I got banned for hate
speech and it was because I was there
was a picture that I tweeted with three
different alt writers that are kind of
like Neo-Nazi people and they were all
uh like mixed race people and I said
like the new alt-right looks like a
Disney Channel original movie in terms
of racial composition and somehow that
got flagged for instigating violence
against minorities I think and I think
that's a tweet that got me banned
because I think that's what showed up in
the final report but I don't know maybe
there were other reasons because nobody
ever communicates but ever since that
account went under it's just been
bandivating ever since so
a ban evading ever since so all my new
accounts are Grand just get banned
because they finally figured out it's me
and then they benefit there's like one
dude at Twitter HQ who's like constantly
looking for my new accounts and they get
me yeah